I love laying in bed on a sunday as much as
the next guy, unless the next guy has to lay
in bed on sunday, monday, tuesday, wednesday,
thursday, friday, saturday, sunday, monday…
Early to bed, early to rise makes space science
move forward. Except the rising part. Just
stay in the bed. That's the message NASA is
putting out there in this new research they're
conducting. Back in 2014, Drew Iwanicki joined
a NASA-funded study excitingly titled Countermeasure
and Functional Testing in Head-Down Tilt Bed
Rest Study -- abbreviated to CFT70. Science
is the best with headlines. Iwanicki was famously
paid 18,000 dollars to lay in bed for 70 days.
He was monitored 24/7, and was only allowed
to sit up onto elbows for 30 minutes while
eating. No napping, no sitting up, no getting
out of bed for ANY reason, plus, constant
monitoring; for two and a half months… It
sounds torturous!
The study simulated long term inactivity in
space in these participants. NASA researchers
figured if participants lay in bed with their
feet slightly elevated their face will get
puffy, and their blood will move differently
-- not unlike in space travel. Doing that
for 70 days should simulate how the body reacts
to long-term spacefaring. They have to be
careful though… because too much bedrest
might not be the best… rest.
Even when bingeing on DNews, sleeping, or
reading a long book, your body is constantly
moving itself. You twitch, you change positions,
and you shift your weight all in an effort
to keep your tissue safe from developing pressure-ulcers.
Pressure-ulcers, also known as bedsores, are
caused when we don't shift our weight and
allow blood to flow throughout our skin. If
the skin is deprived of blood for too long,
it suffocates and dies. If the ulcers reach
Stage IV the tissue damage can reach bone.
Too much bed rest can seriously damage the
human body and in extreme cases can kill;
pressure-ulcers kill 60,000 Americans every
year. Nurses are trained to move paralyzed
patients every 2 hours to minimize bedsores,
but even if you ignore bedsores, bedrest itself
may be harmful to some. A 2004 study in the
journal Joint, Bone, Spine, found patients
with lower back pain who were prescribed bedrest
ended up coming back with chronic pain 17
percent more often.
AND, in a 2008 Journal of Applied Physiology
study, rats who were hindlimb-unloaded, sort
of like bedrest for rats, showed signs of
depression after only two weeks. Eventually,
they developed higher cardiovascular stresses
on top of their psychological issues. Other
studies have found long periods of bedrest
can cause forgetfulness, confusion, anxiety,
and respiratory problems or blood disorders.
Even Hippocrates, considered the Father of
Western Medicine, who died in 370 BC, had
found bedridden patients could experience
muscle loss, bone loss and even tooth loss!
Now, to be clear, science isn't saying bedrest
is evil! Hippocrates would recommend it for
some minor illnesses, and that practice continues
today. A study done at the Boston Children's
Hospital found those who were treated for
concussions who took time to rest their brains
recovered more quickly than those who didn't
rest. A little sloth is good once in awhile!
The concussed kids weren't even allowed to
read, text, or play video games for several
days!
To bring it all back, NASA is studying bedrest
because of deep-space exploration. The CFT70
study is slated to be completed in December
2015, but they hope to "help understand which
mission tasks might be affected by changes
in physiology during space flight and design
countermeasures to prevent or minimize impairment
to these physiological systems" for extended
space flight... Like for going to Mars...
Or further. Hopefully, they'll learn just
how much "muscle, bone and cardiovascular
functions" will be affected thanks to all
that bed rest. Hippocrates would be proud.
if you like digging deep into science of space.
Check out my new show, TestTube Plus. I recently
had astrophysicist Dr. Ian O'Neill on to talk
about black holes, white holes, wormholes,
and all sorts of other spacey crazy for a
whole WEEK
of episodes. TestTube Plus is a deep dive
into science. You can subscribe here or in
the link in the description!! Also it's an
audio podcast on iTunes, which has gotten
pretty good reviews so far!